as a player Joey Barton was one of the
most controversial men in football
outspoken aggressive tempestuous rarely
out of the headlines as a manager it
wasn't much different this week Barton
stirred up a sexism Scandal by launching
a furious broadside against female
pundit analyzing men's football on
television it all began with a post
saying women shouldn't be talking with
any kind of authority in the men's game
come on let's be serious it's a totally
different game I cannot take a thing
they say iy in the men's Arena well
since then he's been called a sexist
misogynist dinosaur but is he saying out
loud what some men maybe many men are
thinking as well well Joey Bon joins me
live now uh Joey great to see you thank
you very much for joining
me P nice to see you you okay looking
well you've had an interesting day uh
take me back to the initial post that
you put up on Twitter clearly
inflammatory but that's your way did you
expect the reaction that you were going
to
get no well it's it's it's part of the
the the um you know when you say what
you what sometimes you're thinking it
can it can obviously lead to you know a
reaction it wasn't entitled you know I
didn't do that I seen or certainly I've
seen in my game where you know I do feel
P I have enough credibility to say I'm
probably a bonafied um expert um this
kind of tokenism creep in especially
when it comes to you know it's ruining
certainly it's ruining my experience of
of both the game and obviously the the
journalistic standards you know it it's
um It's not nothing to do with sex
sexism at
all I mean what is your particular
complaint is it that women have not
played the game to the highest level and
therefore they're not qualified to talk
about
it P look I'm against tokenism and and
I'm against um you know poor
journalistic standards especially when
it comes to the game I love which is
football know know to everyone's game
you know but there's two two slightly
different uh variants obviously the
men's game and and the women's game and
all of a sudden if you speak out in
favor of uh you know saying a men's game
people come to here and you know I'm
getting accused of being rightwing
because of I've said what clearly a lot
of people are thinking about the
journalistic standards of some of the
you know female commentary and ccoms and
punditry that that I'm seeing um in the
game that I feel as I say I think I'm a
Bonafide expert
in I mean you said today uh I stand by
everything I've said on women commenting
and cooms on the men's football like me
talking about knitting or net ball way
out of my comfort zone uh we've gone too
far you can't watch a game now without
hearing the nonsense any man who says
otherwise is an absolute fart parcel I
mean do you accept that some of your
language here was a little
incend well well that is X or Twitter it
was once known that that is what what
those platforms are kind of used for as
as we all use them it's just a tool um
and it it leads to this debate or you
know I don't want to see sexism in
football but if we don't talk about this
properly and debate this properly this
is just going to further rise and and
rise and ruin um as I say the experience
of of watching
you know Elite level men's football and
and as I say every Everywhere You te now
um there's there's for for what I would
deem as an unqualified opinion um
commentating pontificating about the
sport I love and it's it's ruining my
experience of it um and it's it's it's
to fuel this woke agenda and if we're
not careful we're going to in increase
sexism massively because it's it's got
to be a true meritocracy pce we have to
have people who
are let me ask you again you haven't
actually answer that to do those
roles right but the question that I
asked you which you haven't answered yet
what is it about the women that you
think is is inappropriate is it because
they have not played the game at the
highest level of men's
football no p p as you know with me I'll
never not answer the question um no it's
absolutely not that it's about as I say
you have to be there on Merit like you
can't you can't be there to to fit this
woke agenda that we've currently got
going on in society um you know there
you don't have to have played the game
you know lots of managers haven't played
the game at a at a high level lots of
good commentary people haven't played
the game at a high high level kind of
Mark Chapman Rory Smiths are this world
um but they've earned the right via you
know hard work and over a prolonged
period to get into that space obviously
it helps talk about the men's game
if you've played that men's game the
higher the level arguably the better
because it gives you a unique experience
there's a lot of similarities between
both Sports peers absolutely no danger
in that but the men's game has just
played at a completely different speed
with a completely different skill set
needed you know and for someone to stand
there and say I would have done this in
this situation or he's made a mistake
there who have no experience of that um
and and it's not just one or two it's
it's been taken over um you know and
ruins the experience for for most men
and it's the men's game and I feel I
don't I don't want to come across a sex
absolutely not I've got a wonderful
daughter wonderful wife my grandmother
big matriarch I want women at Men's
games you know at Bristol Rovers we had
hair game to and it was a great
initiative to get women in the stadiums
but if we're going to talk about the
technical nuances of of elite level
football and we want to educate the
audience which is the punditry co-
commentary role then we we must do that
with the most credible people not people
who tick boxers or fill quoters and I do
feel that at this moment in time okay
but let me let me put two names to you
you know let me put two names to you or
three names right you've got someone
like Alex Scott who won a World Cup as a
women's player right which is eluded
eluded our men's
team I'm sorry I'm being told she didn't
win the World Cup but she certainly
competed at a very high level for
England for a very long time you've got
Laura Woods who's one of the best I
think one of the best football
presenters in the game she's a woman
she's been Furious today about what you
said um you know what why should people
like that be excluded from the men's
game no I'm absolutely not saying that
I'm saying if you've V the right to be
there with with credibility and and and
Hardware over a long period you should
absolutely be there I've got a daughter
I wondered if she would would like to
Peter to to have the opportunity to
commentate or co- commentate on a men's
game if that what she the men's football
game if that's what you chooses but she
should be there because she's worked
incredibly hard over over aolong period
has got a great skill set not be just
because she's a woman and to fill a
quota and this woke agenda this tokenism
we we have to be very very careful look
look at what it's doing to other sports
and um you know I don't want to see the
sport that I love um ruined and and my
experience as as a man it's ruining I
can't what to tell you now for and and
and a lot of the information is
technically incorrect that that these
so-called experts women experts are
saying about the men's game it the
factually incorrect but but someone but
but Joey someone like Alex Scott right
who has had tremendous success as a
player been very successful as
television presenter is she not
qualified does she not meet your
criteria to talk about the men's game to
talk about the men's game
yeah yeah well she she hasn't played any
she hasn't played in in any any games
I've played in and been involved as a
manager in
657 professional men's games now the
women's games are fantastic game at the
minute thriving I've never seen as many
opportunities you know the England team
wins stuff at that in in the women's
game I think sander vman's done a great
job raising the awareness for the
women's game it's phenomenal but the
men's game and the women's game in this
country are different one's about 20
years old and ones about 30 40 years old
if you go back to kind of dcast the
Bells and and the inception for women
I've lived through it I've played
football with women have no problem but
Joe here's my here's my problem with the
argument right if you look at people
like mson greatest commentator I've ever
seen Barry Davis right up there Clive
tilsley Dez ler right none of them ever
play professional football by your
criteria why are they more qualified
than someone like Alex Scott who is at
least played for her country many times
why are they more qualified having not
played professional football in the end
the rules of football are the same
whether you're male or foot or female
they're exactly the same rules
they're the same rules but it's a
complete
football's about a lot more than rules P
it's time and space and velocity and
impact and challenges and and and the
games are at two different speeds it's
almost like if if I decide Sunday I'm
going to um go to Formula One and I
start saying listen I would have done
this if I was Lewis Hamilton in this
corner and i' have done that and and
rightly kard or or Damon Hill or you
know Eddie Jordan Jordan or whatever
would rightly turn down and say what you
on about say well I drive a car I've got
a driving license yeah but one's going
to 200 mph and one's going to maybe 80
70 mph tops in this country you know the
different speed so to stand there and
pontificate with authority and and
actually when it's factually incorrect
it's infuriating because I love hijack
journalistic standards and I think we're
compromising it with this tokenism and
if if the girls let me ask you question
good enough to get there it should be on
a meritocracy it shouldn't be on this
tokenism because they're filling the
quote and we need to get um someone in
there because it that will lead even
further to to the sexism that we all
want to avoid we want it to be diverse
and inclusive but it has to be credible
we're talking about the best product we
output is in this country is Premier
League football the elite level
football okay but Joey let me ask you
got protect you've never played to my
knowledge and correct me if I'm wrong
you've never played Champions League or
or World Cup football so does that
qualify you yeah to talk not
withstanding you're a very good
professional footballer does that
qualify you by your yard stick to
comment on Champions League football or
World Cup
football P everybody's entitled to
comment every you know I can talk about
Premier League football can talk about
Taekwondo but it's about credibility and
journalistic standards rather than this
as I said this tokenism should be there
on Merit not for quotas and if and
there's loads of you know women managers
you know m is fantastic CA vman we've
spoken about if they come across and
managing the men's game I have no
problem with that if they're the best
the best candidate similar with you know
there is some female pundits out there
who are capable and and and Avent
credibility over a long period but also
there's lots at this moment there's
there's a well I don't want to name
names I'm not here to name names there's
lots of good people um but also the
majority are poor and the standards are
poor and it's factually incorrect
information well I heard the comments
from the Liverpool uh Fulham game about
you know the endo the the Japanese boy
Endo scores and the commentator was
female coom's female and she talks about
Endo scores with his laces now anyone
who watched that who had any knowledge
of football seen that Endo scored with
the side of his foot but no one because
it was female ccoms and and and female
uh commentator no one said I'm going a
minute that didn't happen so if you're a
young impressionable person who doesn't
know and you're coming for high
journalistic standards and content to
educate and inform which is what we're
meant to do if we're in those spots then
then then we have to correct those
mistakes and if and if it goes unchecked
it it it it pulls the standard down and
and we can't allow that to happen for
this woke
agenda over
everything did you think that Alan
Hanson was a good
commentator he's he was
fantastic right so when he said they'll
never win kids about Manchester United
and they won it with kids he made a
terrible mistake I mean does that
discredit
him who who hasn't made a mistake we all
make mistakes but over a prolonged
period you have to have more successes
than failures so to get the opportunity
and this what we have to be careful of
all those great commentators you
mentioned before mty got rest a soul
brilliant of what he did their
opportunities are going to be restricted
because female ex- female players are
getting those opportunities so we got to
be careful here because you know I want
a healthy game where women can go to the
football and enjoy it which they are
I've never seen more women PS out
football matches than what I currently
see or women's opportunities within
football and that's fantastic and long
may that continue we need to be
incredibly inclusive right across the
board but it has to be for people who
are good enough who who've eared the
right to be there I don't care where
you're from how many games you've played
but you have to have a body of work
that's credible to get you there not
just you get an opportunity because you
fill a quoted or you tick a box and
we've got we've got to say it call it
for what it is and the world's gone
crazy all right let's take a short break
when we come back I've got three women
lined up who will be responding to you
Joey but you've agreed to stay and
listen to what they have to say and I'll
get your response to that as well well
welcome back to P when uncensored uh
Joey Barton's given a defense of his
views about female pundits in football
so are female pundits qualified to talk
about the men's game well I've got some
women here who would like to respond uh
and they are
Bianca Westwood who was the first ever
female football reporter for soccer
Saturday Paul Davis is a youtubing
antifeminist and Kate B is a co-founder
and presenter of the offside Rule and
football 365 all right let me start with
you Bianca I'd imagine that you were
going slightly nuts as you heard that
but maybe I I I don't want to speak for
you what is your
response yeah absolutely I mean usually
I wouldn't give those kinds of opinions
any particular Credence but the way in
which he tweeted especially calling out
the young girl the vlogger from
Manchester City I just thought it was
out of order because I've been on the
the wrong end of dogs abuse when I very
first started reporting and it it it it
didn't sit well with me this is a young
girl she's on social media she's not
presenting news night she's not saying
she's an expert in football she's there
because viewers of football are changing
we're getting more stream
we're getting more influences and and
that's that's a different argument
entirely so that's particularly the
reason why I didn't like what he said
but who is qualified to speak on
football then because I've been watching
the game for over 40 years my first game
at West Ham was before Joey Barton was
even born um I've been watching the game
the whole time I've watched hours and
hours and hours of football I worked
behind the scenes at Sky for 10 years
before I was even given a shot on camera
watching many of my male colleagues who
were probably not always as good as I
was getting chances that I was never
given so I don't really understand
exactly what you need to know how long
do we need to work in the game behind
the scenes before we're allowed on on
camera to be a pundit you know the laws
are the same I can read a game of
football Emma Hayes Serena vman can both
read games of football are you saying
that they can't provide Insight it
sounds to me like Joey's got a problem
with particular female pundits who to
his knowledge haven't done enough in the
game but how does he know and and how do
do we quantify and qualify that because
there are efl players who are commenting
cooms being pundits on Champions League
games what level do you have to get to
before you're allowed as far as Joey
Barton is concerned to be able to be a
pundit on the men's game well that's a
that's a yeah that's a good question let
me bring in Kate Kate what is your
response to Joey B I think it's really
clear that Joey doesn't appreciate that
women can study journalism too and they
can study Sports journalism and if
you're Bianca Westwood you can watch
thousands of hours of football and
commentate and Report into a Sky Sports
Studio as she did for decades on the
men's game and be very informed there
has to be something more to this I think
look let's take Alex Scott okay she's
got a degree in sports writing and
broadcasting she's played for England
140 times times she played for her Club
career over two decades how is she not
qualified to talk about the game just
like any other pundit whether you're
talking about Mark Chapman Jake
Humphries none of them have played the
game but they've done the same as the
rest of us they've studied journalism
they love the game and they're
expressing their learned opinion and
assessment on the game I don't
understand why that's so
tricky well Pearl I can see you rolling
your eyes there you clearly don't
agree well I keep seeing women given
special handouts and special treatment
I'm seeing the same thing that he's
seeing you know um one thing you didn't
put in in my bio is I'm actually a
semi-pro athlete I've been involved in
athletics for 20 years um and no men and
women's sports are not the same men jump
higher they run faster so I I see where
he's coming from when I was listening to
him talk he was talking about the best
person for the job should be the one
that gets it I I didn't see anything
wrong with what he said but some of the
women who are getting these jobs are the
best women I mean I at I've looked at
their Instagrams they look like
influencers I mean I mean come on I
don't understand why you is an
influence the one the one girl you guys
brought up earlier I I didn't know her
but I've seen women's soccer um or sorry
football here I'm in the UK um but
women's football they they make it into
an agenda and it becomes a political
agenda and I hate it it ruins the
sanctity of women's sports then it just
becomes all about this woke nonsense I I
agree with him I think it needs to be
the best person for the job I think it
is the best person for the job and I
don't know what kind of problem Joey's
got is this a woman's
problem s effectively Jo is saying Joe
is saying that his eight nyear old
daughter can never grow up to be a
football commentator yes why do you guys
put words well how is she different how
is she different if she goes stud
journalism let about the game let me
bring joy
back just like Kelly Kat how's that
different all right let's Joey's been
listening to all this
Joy well
said I take on board every you know I've
known I've known Bianca being in around
the game for as long as she has and
she's worked incredibly hard and does a
fantastic job she I wouldn't say
Bianca's there on token
that's not what you know she's worked
incredibly hard and has AED that
recognition and reward within the
industry but that's not everybody that's
in the game on the female commentary
side that's not and as the as the lady
rightly points out there she's seeing
exactly what I've said this is not
sexism this is saying the best person
for the opportunity should get that role
we've seen when when an inch has been
given in other sports you know I think
you know maybe in your collegate
swimming we've seen huge problems with
um L Thomas and Riley Gaines and I don't
want to even go into that but we got to
be careful that we we promote the best
person for for the job who's worked the
hardest to get there and for for me in
the in the com the sport that I believe
I'm a Bonafide expert the women haven't
reached the level in the commentating
and punditry of the men you know and and
and they getting opportunities that we
strict the men's opportunities and
that's wrong we shouldn't create we
should create a meritocracy the best who
work the hardest with the most ability
get get on and and get better and get
rewarded
let me let me just say something come to
I'll come to wait a minute wait a minute
time out everybody I want to just
readback Joey's own words with that
first tweet it wasn't a question of
meritocracy you said women shouldn't be
talking with any kind of authority in
the men's game come on let's be serious
it's a completely different game Bianca
there was no there was no meritocracy
there it was all
women okay no no no listen Bianca do you
think the Bianca can I just ask you a
question question and I respect your
opinion massively I respect your opinion
massively do you think the women's game
and the men's game is the same
game the laws of the game are exactly
the same the same rules apply you know
whether it's yellow card red card
offside you can read the game it's still
exactly the same there's two goals and
11 players play can BR have you ever
been tackled at full speed it's about
that have you ever been tackled at full
speed by a fully grown man
Andes CH op to do with it you seem to
have changed your opinion Joey when you
were earlier you had a problem with
women who waly to talk about the
game around to talk about the game and
now you're saying the game's different
what you have a problem with he's
changing his mind he's changing his mind
all the time have you got a problem with
the journalistic coverage or have you
got a problem with the playing of the
game please don't all talk over each
other
you're just shouting at me I can't hear
you being a top player doesn't mean
you're serious conversation this is
becoming a fast but not all the men's
game I'm here to talk about giving these
women a chance Joey you're
not get CH by you to have a sensible
conversation not everybody is a
consumate broadcaster when they very
first start did you ever see Gary
Neville when he was first on Monday
Night Football he said himself he wasn't
brilliant
you have to learn on the job when you're
live you can't learn live television
anywhere but live television that
doesn't mean they don't know anything
about the game maybe they're just not
brilliant at broadcasting yet when I
start is that women keep getting
absolutely terrorized she's not than
anyone else you've not done you've not
done this either I got absolutely
terrorized when I first started live
reporting because people said I knew
nothing about football that wasn't the
case I've been watching football since I
was we're not talking about you I wasn't
a great broadcaster
at maybe these female pundits have to be
given a chance now I get men coming up
to me she talking foring how great I am
i' like to know I'd like to know from
Joey Bart which which women are not
qualified to do this because I see some
very talented you give one name some
really good job and I'd like to know
which ones do not deserve it's a one
name Jo before Man City so he should
tell us is are you guys let me ask Joy
one name Joey is someone you don't think
is up to
it one name Bianca would you like one
name one name one name I'm not even I'm
not I'm not even going there I'm I don't
have to give his anything I've come on
sensibility debate and you just want to
shout the problem is Jo when you talk
about all right i' got to leave it there
when you talk about this I'm going to
leave it there all I would say listen
Everyone's entitled their opinion all I
listen we got to leave it there all I
would say is I I do think think Joey I
do think Joey's being a bit unfair if
you talk about all women in your Tweet
and then you won't name a single woman
you actually personally object to but
think it should be a meritocracy that is
a confusing message but look I will say
also as I end this I will say this I
will say now we've ended the debate I
will say this there are a lot of men who
I saw replying to Joey and they've
replied to us who agree with him so this
is a debate that probably ought to be
aired and we've had it and I appreciate
you all joining me so thank you very
much
entitled